[Musique]
va s'achever bonjour bonjour merci
d'être sur le plateau de tv 78 pour
henvic qui vous est entièrement consacré
vous êtes ici en tant que photographe
photographe versaillais vous avez une
belle actualité là dans les jours et les
mois qui suivent
on va donc en parlait volontiers bon ben
ça tombe bien ouf
dites moi donc avant de vous consacrer à
l'art à la photo et je crois aussi à la
musique et la poésie
mais que faisiez-vous donc à s a secret
non c'est pas un secret elle a dit
l'avoir pour moi je suis né à versailles
nul n'est parfait
j'ai grandi dans la musique et je me
suis compléter cette dimension musicale
par des études aussi scientifique et
historique d'accor à la sorbonne et où
ponts et chaussées très bien ce qui m'a
surtout donné l'occasion de sécher tous
les cours pour organiser une immense
fête au château de versailles avec 52
écoles d'art oui et pour créer ensuite
un projet quelques années après qui
s'appelait wanadoo donc pour les jeunes
c'est ça commence à être un peu anciens
et c'est la création du multimédia en
france
ah c'était dans ce décor à peu près
c'était en 95 a été lancée
officiellement 96 et moi j'ai quitté en
99 2000
parce que là on avait une croissance
immense et un peu moins de créativité à
l'époque et donc ça vous plaisez moir
donc ça me plaisait - et je suis
retournée donc c'est assez vite aux
conférences et à la transmission soit
multimédia c'est de la transmission d'un
ciel avec l'image mais je me suis
retourné mais amour de toujours qui sont
la photographie la musique là qu'on fait
d'eux les conférences et des rencontres
d'accord est ce que la photo si j'ai
bien compris vous en faites depuis au
moins 30 ans si ce n'est plus alors vous
avez des thèmes de prédilection enfin
non je voulais te dire un truc d'abord
en fait vous vous considérez comme un
vagabond vous m'avez dit c'est vrai ça
veut dire j'ai un vagabond moi c'est
pour moi c'est quelqu'un qui est
alors il peut y avoir une connotation un
peu péjorative peu importe en tout cas
l'archétype du vagabond pour moi c'est
de charlie chaplin
c'est à dire c'est à dire celui qui
découvre en permanence où qu'ils aillent
qui n'est jamais hasseni à sa place
entre guillemets ni en place donc il
bouge tout le temps il rencontre en
permanence ils découvrent et il utilise
avec une virtuosité et beaucoup d'humour
les environnements dans lesquels ils se
trouvent ils déplacent les équilibres et
les remet en cause
et de manière très humble c'est un c'est
un homme qui est parfaitement
parfaitement un pas du tout dans la
grande société
il utilise le génie de la création de la
créativité de la vitalité et qui aussi
ce génie des rencontres d'accord donc
c'est quelque chose qui est
effectivement maniement en tant que
vagabond je je je je le dis aussi voit
beaucoup plus humblement mais parce que
à 26 ans je suis parti en inde et que
c'était quand même un pays où il ya
beaucoup de tagab là aussi un peu plus
grave au sens propre
d'accord et du coup j'imagine que vous
en avez rapporté moult photographie
alors quelques dizaines de milliers
voilà alors recentrons nous sur
l'actualité oui vous avez des eaux pour
l'instant sélectionné deux thèmes de qui
vous sont chers apparemment dont un qui
est bizarrement assez classique tracé
déjà vu même si je puis dire c'est un
sacré toupet parce que vous n'êtes pas
le premier à le faire donc vous avez
photographié les statuts du parc
oui je sais tout ça et mais alors c'est
pas nouveau fait à nouveau alors voilà
donc on les voit ses photos alors
effectivement de quelle façon les avez
vous traitez avec quel regard pour leur
donner une vraie originalité
alors j'ai d'abord j'ai choisi non pas
de faire une exposition ou de faire un
livre même si on va en parler
oui alors qu'ils s'appellent politique
des statuts les jardins du château de
versailles
l'idée c'était depuis l'âge de 12 ans de
découvrir ce parc
mais comme énormément de gens disent
trouve qu'il ya un an ou deux ans mon
épouse m'a dit mais tu devrais les
montrer plutôt que de les garder pour
toi les montrer et j'ai fait deux
expositions l'une en juin juillet
l'autre en octobre à versailles à
versailles
effectivement et j'ai eu la chance de
voir qu effectivement les versailles et
et puis les gens de la région du 78
sièges ou les actes en jean louis qui
viennent était assez on va dire
émerveillé de redécouvrir ses statuts
des lumières des saisons et un regard
qu'effectivement j'ai bel politique
là vous voyez un angelot là on a beau
rêve de briller
alors bien sûr après il peut y avoir des
compositions artistiques et
photographiques ici c'est un des deux
angelots sur le vin
et j'ai mis en effet miroir d'accord ils
sont exactement les mêmes mais dans la
réalité il y en a bien deux même s'ils
sont un tout petit peu différent main de
l'autre la hotoie exactement les mêmes
alors si on veut voir cette exposition
oui la caisse comptait alors on peut
soutenir l'idée que le château de
versailles développe des expositions de
photographies également mais en
attendant catherine pégard mac et la
présidence du château de versailles qui
a beaucoup aimé aussi le travail que
j'ai pu montrer jeu
mais inviter à la fois essayer de
publier ce livre et les photographier
les tableaux photographiques sont
visibles donc à lagence richelieu
d'accord qui sont des présentes rue
carnot 45 rue carnot donc à versailles à
une exposition qui dure assez longtemps
d'ailleurs qui dure trois mois après
mois en parallèle vous une une
conférence que je donne sur le bassin de
latone en particulier non ça c'est votre
côté historiens plutôt historien et en
musique
d'accord ces musiciens est alors
pourquoi ce bassin de latone il ya
quelque chose de très extraordinaire
trouve c'est que d'abord à lille et
c'est le premier pas c'est un convoi
quand on a la galerie des glaces
derrière soi et qu'on va vers le grand
canal sellal immenses perspectives et
c'est le premier bassin convoi mais
c'est un bassin on est obligé de
contourner
on ne regarde pas forcément et l'idée là
ça a été pour moi de m'approcher en
toute saison et donc depuis 35 ans à peu
près et de montrer pourquoi ce cas des
personnages comme ça qui se trouve à
différents étages en plus de la ds la
tonne qui a deux enfants qui sont à la
fois apollon le dieu du soleil et
d'irène sa soeur qui est la déesse de la
lune pourquoi louis xiv a laissé des
artistes composer un ensemble
architectural du sculptural avec une
femme
à l'époque c'est quand même très moderne
mes deux enfants
bien sûr il ya paul on en aurait pu
imaginer qu'il dit je souhaite que ce
soit apollon dieu du soleil qui l'aurait
présentée tout seul et enfants c'est pas
le cas et on voit ces personnages qui
sont assez curieux une femme paysanne
qui ouvre la bouche de manière immense
un peu plus être qu'on va là à gros ça à
gauche et vous voyez les sa bouche
ressemble à celle des grenouilles des
grenouilles l'homme le paysan il ya
quatre doigts on a un plus un regain
d'intérêt
il a quatre il a une jambe qui est
beaucoup plus courte que la normale tout
simplement parce qu'une transformation
alors on parle beaucoup d'évolutions de
progrès de nouveaux mondes et c'est là
on est dans quelque chose qui figure une
régression symbolique
les paysans ont refusé de donner à la
donne de l'eau pour ses enfants et pour
elle-même et étant une déesse et
demandant à ce qu'il me fasse preuve
simplement de générosité et e confirmant
leur refus on a un conflit qui n'est
dans l'app initiants tu ça sent la
punition est la malédiction
vocationnelle ce en leur disant vous
voulez rester là et bien vive et
transformé à jamais en crapaud
merci c'est que cette conférence montre
cette transformation
cette symbolique et là ça mollit pas
d'enjeu vous couple elle est partout
chaque chaque chose veut dire quelque
chose mais comme vous dites ce bassin
qui ont contourné qu'on ne regardent
peut-être pas assez
oui donc il faut que sur sur la tonne
est tout ce qu'il ya derrière et en
musique
ces hangars mais d'imprégner peut-être
plus les sentiments des situations que
chacun des personnages vie que soient
les enfants que ce soit cette femme que
ce soit ces paysans d'accord parfait
donc sa stature j finalement oui très
bien vous mettez en scène voilà alors
cette conférence faut pas la louper
parce que elle a lieu une fois oui c'est
donc mercredi 12 décembre à 20h30 alors
service d'ordre qui auraient des des
rebeus lot on sait jamais d'où sans
doute sans doute temps mise en doute
alors on va passer au deuxième thème
aussi qui est prépondérant dans votre
carrière photographique d'avoir le thème
des mains que vous avez choisi pour une
autre exposition
alors les mains toujours pareil vous
partez d'un portrait vous fait un gros
plan sur les mains pas comment vous
travaillez ce ça et pourquoi
non je travaille à l'intuition d'une
part et avec une intention qui est de
pouvoir effectivement photographique
dans tous les pays du monde où jouer que
ce soit l'ethiopie la scène en inde
voilà là on a quitté sète on est très
loin on quitte un peu le domaine des
dieux mais on se rapproche de ce qui est
parfois très émouvant et très divin
aussi dans les gestes ou très gracieux
que ce soit chez les hommes les enfants
les femmes et dans des gestes du
quotidien ou dans le travail rural
urbain est telle qu'ils soient comment
vous faites pour entrer en contact avec
ces personnes que vous photographier eh
bien je vais tout simplement vivre et
partager avec eux c'est à dire c'est à
dire je vous inviter à dîner arrive
comme un vagabond avec mon baluchon ce
soit dans une plantation de thé où que
ce soit ici ou là ça c'est en ethiopie
c'est tout enfin c'est un jeune homme et
qui se cache derrière il ya beaucoup de
depuis donc la main est à la fois
l'outil de protection et on tend la main
et éventuellement aussi
ouais donc c'est tout c'est tous ces
regards donc vous avez votre vue sur
seules épaules
voilà vous vous présenter j'arrive je
partage je découvre aussi leur métier ou
leur manière de vivre
je partage pendant deux trois ou quatre
jours vous les aider à travailler
finalement j'ai travaillé je vous
l'avais coup je les observe oui j'ai de
bonnes vacances et c'est plutôt que je
découvre comment ils vivent
dakar est pour eux voir un étranger qui
prend du temps et qui va pas voler des
images mais qui hélas sans son appareil
à bord oui d'abord pour être en contact
ça ouvre des choses et à un moment donné
la part exacte ya peut être un témoin
tout simplement
et donc là ils sont éventuellement
d'accord ou pas pour être photographiés
bon général le sont en général le sont
parce que quand vous créez un lien à
moins qu'ils aient une
un refus religieux we live ça bien sûr
que ça arrive votre show oui toujours
on sait pas forcément
localisé dans bon c'est donc il ya un
certain nombre de pays on est quel
logiciel usage aussi où on n'a pas
tellement envie des photographies des
blessures ou des petites filles où les
jeunes filles par exemple jet d'un homme
elles peuvent avoir envie de se cacher
leur pudeur leur job ou de montrer leur
beauté ça qui fait la richesse de votre
exposition vous pouvez j'encourage tout
le monde à les voir donc cette faute
cette expo pas dans sur le thème des
mains elle sera où et quand
alors elle démarre lundi prochain lundi
10 décembre pour 15 jours jusqu'au 23
décembre et alors à la gare de saint
simon qui est juste dans la rue ce
ciment entre le cinéma et roxanne voilà
donc c'est à versailles la galice à ses
mots ces petites galeries petite balle
ou péquiste à côté du cinéma roxane mais
comme vous dites donc là pendant 15
jours 15 jours de 11h à 19h30 tous les
jours bompard et après il ya une autre
expo encore à l'éclat de verre je crois
c'est ça alors ça c'est une autre expo
qui a été demandé par l'éclat des acquis
danse d'une galerie photographique en
france et ils m'ont demandé de venir
exposer de manière très longue
des portraits des portraits d'hommes de
femmes d'enfants de tous âges et il y en
a de tous pays bien sûr
et donc il ya des tableaux qui sont en
grand et le travail qu'ils ont fait est
assez remarquable je trouve est-ce qui
est d'encadrer au tableau c'est qu'ils
ont non cadrée certains en grand format
et puis un ado qu'ils ont tiré sûr très
grand format en plexi donc les
différents formats pour les gens qui
sont passionnés par la décoration
intérieure par le lien aussi par la
lumière
on a eu l'occasion de voir chez les
spécialistes de l'encadrement en france
un certain nombre de tableaux
photographies artistiques très humain
mais deux sur des supports très
différents et donc est rendu très
différents outils modernes et très
moderne bon ben écoutez bravo pour cette
belle actualité bien des remplier donc
on a on va aller remplir nous nos yeux
bon vieux livre il édifie juste ajoute
un mot il est pour l'instant pas en
librairie parce que je suis à méjanes
cherche éditeurs cherchent éditeurs mais
j'ai des personnes de contacter
l'éditeur hockey et puis face à chauray
donc merci à très bientôt
j'imagine que sur le site on peut le
trouver lorsque je préfère art of point
fr à la retouche la retouche pardon
merci vincent sera bientôt au revoir
votre journée
[Musique]